iceland can be harsh like a like a lunar
landscape
but it can also be vivid and green
[Music]
and i have these moments when i'm biking
to work and it's dark
and i can see the stars and i can see
the moon
a harsh
winter and a
long night can also be beautiful and
when the
summer finally arrives it brings out the
joy
and you really
really reconnect it to people who live
here again
the really close-knit community
and
being a part of that matters to me
[Music]
sir can you just introduce yourself
yes my name is olipot gaizon and i serve
as the chief data officer at the city of
reykjavik
[Music]
the data scientist finds the story in
the data
[Music]
when i started here
i felt like it was a clean slate
[Music]
our mission was to build something
we know
that digital transformation is ahead
we need to
evolve with society
how can we
as a city
use data and data analytics
to help people
to have them accessible on the web
to
put down these barriers these walls
to improve
the quality of life for the residents of
reykjavik
so you your work means something to
somebody
[Music]
our role here
as
data science office
is to bring value
from data
to our stakeholders within the city of
reykjavik
the stakeholders could be
the department of school and leisure it
could be the department of welfare urban
planning or city council or the
residence it's almost like going through
the phone book or something like that
but you have to
go there
talk to them
listen and do it again and again and
again
we are
just right outside the arctic circle so
during the winter it gets dark
and it's obviously cold in iceland
so
the first thing you kind of get to know
about icelanders is that they are
crazy about their swimming pools
[Music]
it's ingrained in our culture you know
when you have family photos you maybe go
to the countryside and take photos but
my brother for instance
got a photographer to meet them up at
the swimming pool because that's where
they were every day essentially so his
family photos
you know them standing by the swimming
pool you know
i got frequent requests even phone calls
on
why can't i see how many guests are in
the swimming pools right now i need to
know this and also like why can't i just
predict how many
people are going to be in the pools for
next next hour or so or two hours or
or in different swimming pools
and what we would like to do is show
so the percentage the capacity of the
swimming pool like oh logarithmically
which is one of the cool swimming pools
here is at 50 right now
and we predict it's going to be at 70 in
an hour and 35
in two hours
so we started looking into this and this
became a project on our side and with
with the department of sports and visa
but when we started to dive into it we
we saw that hey this is going to be a
bit complicated
i should be looking at you and not the
camera yeah okay
start now yeah talking to you okay so
that who the heck are you
if i knew no i'm kidding
my name is incarosconostate my name is
leonard hatkinson my name is my name is
thorpe sorenson i'm a senior data
scientist i am a data scientist data
scientist a project manager for
reykjavik city reykjavik gregory city
the city of reykjavik my role is
modeling
advanced analytics and predictive
modeling yeah that's me i guess finding
meaning or value and something that
looks like chaos at first and finding a
meaningful and beautiful way to present
it to
put a structure on the data team's work
how to break it down and help them keep
their
deadlines nothing ever happens too
quickly for me
we have like different backgrounds and
different skill sets within the team
thought is an amazing you know machine
learning
guru but he's also like he has this you
know eye for detail and you know
there's there's something of an artist
about him
not leaner is
he's a great programmer and what happens
when your team ignores your deadlines
they never do
[Music]
we have these gates
and it counts so many guests arriving
into the pool we can say okay this is
just a cumulative sum of people that
have gone swimming today that's a bit of
a pickle because we really don't want to
know how many people have been counted
in hey there are 10 000 people in the
pool like that that makes no sense
can we fix that without buying new gate
so changing the protocol
turned out that we have
historical data for in and out of the
gates
for one
swimming pool nicely the largest
swimming pool it's because there you
have these bracelets that you need to
hand in when you when you go out
so we contacted the hardware provider
and they provided us with historical
data and the data is corrected with
respect to these bracelets and
afterwards so we have the data on how
long they're staying there is a
distributional property that we can
extract out of it but to make things a
little bit more complicated if there's a
cue
of people trying to leave the swimming
pool
the people
who work at the swimming pools are kind
enough to like oh we'll just open the
gates for you you don't have to you
don't have to use your car to leave but
that's wonderful for everybody except
for the data people because that roads
are data essentially but it's
we look at it like it's it's the
kindness of man ruining our perfect
structured data
so we have to account for that
discrepancy
[Music]
our model is a very simple one it's a
linear splines model
and the only inputs are time of the day
day of the week and time of the year
every five minutes we have a process
in web methods that reads data from the
swimming pool gate
and stores them in our data lake we then
use the pinch packets
we get
pinned linear models from our studio
connect
and
we then predict
the duration then we pin that results
table in our studio connect and that's
what
our shiny app accesses
so before launching it it had to go to
testing to make sure that this is you
know grounded in reality because we are
not swimming pool executives we don't
really know these numbers we set up a
separate shiny app for the managers of
the swimming pools so going through the
testing
it matters to it to go fast to quickly
deliver quickly and in a way that they
understand to show them the numbers show
them the time series and and preferably
live
so it's just like an interactive gt plot
so you just hover over like this is the
time now it's
half past 12. the app says that there
are you know 50 people here let's let's
do a count the feedback was like
it's essentially 10 minutes later
everything is spot on and we thought
okay is there something we need to
improve and they said no this is fine
because that's maybe how long it takes
for you to walk there or bike or
ride your car there or when we lost it
it was immediately well received by the
residents of reykjavik
like a lot of
how we
are able to
get things off the ground quickly has to
do with our
and our studio connect
so when you do it often enough you have
kind of
you have all the tools and you just have
to pick and choose what works best
we are the people that actually work
with the data but now we're also the
people that can deploy this and schedule
it and you know put up a shiny app in
production within a week
all the process of transforming and
building up these analytical tables or
products and publishing it
the data science team
if it can't do all of that inside one
domain
they become superheroes they can do
everything
[Music]
i think i do what i do
not only because i love coding and
making beautiful things but also because
i believe that working at the city of
reykjavik
i can
improve people's lives
if only a small fit
making a difference
and maybe it's small at least it's
making
an impact which hopefully ends with
the citizens and
making life better for them
if you want to make changes if you want
to matter
then you need to embrace the fact it's
going to be challenging
you have to just know it's going to be a
ride
that's something that
i didn't quite realize the magnitude of
it before i started
but that's a ride worth taking
because through the experience you grow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you